In the last exercise that you did with Sarah, something remarkable happened.
Here we have a string we call toUpperCase. And then, we look at what's in the
variable on which we just invoked the method. And we notice that it does not
contain the upper case version. So, calling this method did not modify or as we
say, mutate the object. We say that toUpperCase is an accessor method, it
leaves the object on which it is called unchanged. Instead, it returns a value
and that value is then stored in this variable. The uppercased string is here,
the original string is still here. Contrast that with that method call. Here we
have a picture and we call the translate method on it. When the method is
called, the picture changes. It is moved to a different location. We say the
object has been mutated. It is now different than what it was before. And we
call the translate method a mutator. So again, an accessor leaves the object on
which it operates unchanged, and mutator changes or mutates the object.